what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
Wednesday finale what a journey it's
been John how are you I am very excited
and I'm also not ready to let go I am
filled with woe to do so how are you
good don't worry we'll milk it yeah so
much Wednesday today they should season
two predictions everything ladies and
gentlemen first off I want to thank you
all who have been on this journey with
us it has been a really fun ride I know
we relate to it unfortunately didn't get
a single thing spoiled so thank you guys
for being awesome leave a like we ask
that kindly helps out the video please
go ahead and leave a like if you're
excited for season two and I know you
are also subscribe and click that
notification Bell because I'm sure
there's something I'll pop up on this
channel that you're gonna be like yeah I
like that and uh full-length retro watch
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy of Wednesday available for our
super sexy rejects over there we cover
exclusively several shows of reaction
highlights and watch alongs included I
want to thank everyone who has shown
their support by joining our patreon
page thus far all right John you ready
to begin this journey let's do it I'm
ready as it'll ever be let's go
[Music]
you
who's your master I was surprised you
wanted to see me again after you ran out
the other night
is this a date no
you try to capture him what's going on
so if you're warned me about you but I
didn't listen
ironic now huh ironic would have been
framing Xavier for murder while the real
hide helped me put him away
I'm not a monster and if you really
thought that I was why would you risk
bringing me out to the woods to confront
me alone you said I was alone oh she's
got her friends and a big net
oh Xavier wasn't invited because he's in
jail
he's there in spirit and I'm out of here
actually
you're coming with us ah no pendants oh
siren perhaps if I hadn't been so
distracted by my own mother hogging this
photo I would have noticed yours sooner
whoa your father fell in love and
married an outcast
oh cool she was a hide
and your father has been living his life
in dread never really quite sure whether
or not she had passed her condition on
to you you're basing all this awesome
Vision you had after we kissed I mean is
that something you could trust
oh yeah just some light torture cut his
head off
you mean serious
there's only one thing that a Hyde
understands
pain
oh yeah that's it I'm out
dude guys I didn't sign up for this
let's go to Weems explain everything
Weems won't help and Tyler here is
always one step ahead of his father you
need at least one witness Bianca stay
dude hostile four is cool whatever
impress him on his mother or any
sensitive issue he's
becoming cold and detached it's like I'm
talking to a different person I believe
the trauma of losing his mother may have
left Tyler with deeper psychological
scars than I suspected oh he is like a
real Jekyll and Hyde situation huh yeah
but who's the master
Sheriff Galvin we have a problem
[Music]
10 names Wednesday atoms
Let's test your reflexes
[Music]
yeah gotta torture faster
hey Wednesday if you still want to go on
a date
you know just let me know
I go to your quad when I gave you that
call from the cave did you already know
the truth Wednesday that's enough Xavier
Thorpe is our height we've got evidence
thanks to you and that's why I'm giving
you one last pass Tyler is going to turn
on you too oh
is that your plan
ask a question
what does it feel like
what does what feel like
to lose
what
I like it covered in blood no idea what
happened but over time
started to remember
everything no oh no dude
panic in her eyes
fear is so Primal I could taste it
and it was delicious
oh man
[Music]
you have no idea
the storm is coming Miss Adams
[Music]
creep
sociopath it's not a Jekyll and Hyde
it's all hide perhaps if you'd come to
me with your suspicions rather than
taking matters into your own hands we
could have worked together oh yes
because trust and cooperation I've
always been the Hallmarks of our
relationship
pack your steamer trunks we will have
them shipped and say your goodbyes son
of a [ __ ]
Tyler used me to frame you he is the
actual-eyed there's some revenge for
back in the day I should have believed
you but since you seem to have some sort
of psychic connection to the hide I was
curious to know if you've drawn anything
recently that might shed some light on
this side yeah so I'll get you out of
here yeah I mean Enemy of My Enemy I
tried being your friend
look where that got me this isn't about
a savior no it's about you every time
you get people get hurt you're toxic
slip it under all you ever do is make
things worse foreign
go far away and never come back and
never return
I hope his thought process is
immediately followed by that was my one
chance damn it do I get another phone
call she doesn't have a phone she's the
only one who knows the truth will you
forget about me the mark you have left
on me is indelible
anytime I grow nauseous at the side of a
rainbow I hear a pop song that makes my
ears bleed
I'll think of you
I always believe relying on other people
to be a sign of weakness
that inevitably they would lead me to
disappointment
facts
ended up in the disappointment
wow
this prophecy cannot come true if I'm
not here
but it kills me to leave when Tyler is
still walking around free if he tries
anything we have a school full of
Gorgons vampires and werewolves ready
and waiting
we've got this Wednesday I promise
we'll take down Lord Voldemort I got a
text from Eugene's moms he woke up last
night
maybe we need to let you drop by on your
way to the station Eugene's got the
answers
so we're gonna
not hugging is kind of our thing
by the end of the episode
glad to see you're finally awake
I heard you visited me all the time
don't ever mention it again someone set
fire to that cave just for a moment
thought that they weren't black
they were red
it is all right okay yeah that's right
damn it damn talked about it in the
review of last episode that might be her
I should have known it was you
faking your death
securing a job and Nevermore unlocking a
hide typically I have great admiration
for well-executed Revenge plots but
yours was a bit extreme
even for my high standards
she left the dance and went to back to
the dance I guess so yeah
and correctly accused kimbot of using
hypnosis to unlock him would you use a
plant derived chemical didn't you yeah
of course you manipulated him by showing
him what his mother truly was now what
Tyler didn't realize is that the truth
wouldn't free him
interesting and that was scary at first
I used the cave and the shackles
ugh
that's enough
I showed you who you really are
and what they did to your mother I hope
Tyler confesses to someone else prior we
were never getting on that train
I sent Tyler to intercept you
I never made it to the station
[Music]
of course I was like why is he why is he
agreeing with her now please don't make
this more difficult than what already is
Marilyn
[Music]
I feel like we should have prepared for
that
oh come on
oh you gotta be kidding me the mouth
foam the past repeats
no
nitrate poisoning A fitting end don't
you think
oh [ __ ] who the hell damn it
thing
damn I'm bummed principal Williams and
her went in front of Miss Thornhill but
I haven't heard a Pete from either of
them why would they confront the
Stoneham because she's behind and it's
happened she's the bad guy bad woman
she's a really bad person
slow down what happened
[Music]
huh what the hell is going on what about
Wednesday
Tyler and Thornhill took her
down to the Old Mill
you need to call the sheriff mom I've
got to go Wednesday's my only friend and
if she's in trouble I've gotta help her
type code
I've code go Rogue Eugene you know we
have roots that go all the way back to
just crack snow
so you come from a line of psychotic
Killers too yep my family has remained
committed
to crack Stone's Mission I decided to
take a different approach
the supernatural
Tyler's been collecting all of these
body parts to resurrect crack Stone
oh damn a Frankenstein's monster he's
gonna be an outcast by Design you are
the key goody sealed crack Stone in his
sarcophagus with a blood lock
only one of her direct descendants can
open it perfect that's her that's her
something's going on at Livermore okay
get a couple cars over there ASAP
the tires of all the squad cars have
been slashed
[ __ ] sure
yeah I've been waiting to do that spin
you better be ready to kill your own son
I'd be ready I'd be prepping all my life
[Music]
it's always the palm
thank you
what's cracks don't gonna come out as
a totally normal guy until the cracks
though
can you hand me my arm please
[Music]
it's like the mummy
[Music]
ah yes
foreign
[Music]
God I love this what a fun spooky
episode yes
oh it looks fairly normal my Vengeance
will be Swift and true
[Music]
as will mine yeah let's do this
oh what the [ __ ]
[Music]
we're ouch
how could she survive that she murdered
Weems and then took Wednesday to crack
Stone's correct we have to get everyone
in the school to safety before it's too
late because this is what's coming so
how do we get everyone out
we'll use our siren song to convince him
cool
coerce everyone into saving themselves
what's going on Bianca's mom's app
season two bringing down a cult crack
storm must be stabbed through his black
heart
it's the only way you will be vanquished
now and forever
is your spectral vision impaired I'm
dying my mother told me it was for
Conjuring Visions it is also a conduit
for contouring spirits it will allow me
to pass through you and heal you
just know once I do you will never see
me again one-time use
[Music]
yeah really looks like I've been in the
same shot yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
it's
like a doctor who energy transfer
what the hell is going on danger is on
its way no time
follow me I definitely remember that
character yep
he was great I think during the Poke
something coaching somebody
yes
all right girl let's do this
oh my God oh my God oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this will not end well for you
Daniel here we go
nice
so before he must have taken his clothes
off
yes
eat it
[Applause]
I can't tell you how I've long for this
moment what it means for my family
come by tongue from direction now
wow some things I guess your hero
I like the makeup on crack Stone I will
expunge your Abominations
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
yes yes
it's a great reaction
it's time to talk about your mother
Tyler the sun is that really you
all right
damn this is crazy damn this is crazy
eyes
slanky monster fight
[Music]
now get her a towel everyone needs a
modesty towel
[Music]
on Wednesday dude
he got godric Gryffindor Sword of the
Sorting Hat how he howdy
pilgrim
s
Archer oh that was
it's okay hold up magnum Zoolander still
cool oh
selfless oh my God everybody go get them
out of here
fly them out on your large Ravens
[Music]
everything
ow nice you just yanked that out because
damn it's probably ripped a bigger hole
in your shoulder
defense is coming back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
no
[Music]
is that a promise
Eugene
please tell me it's Eugene
nice
[Music]
finally damn
wow
cool damn
oh
merchandise
this [ __ ] God damn it I might not get
to kill all the outcasts but at least
I'll get to kill you Wednesday nice
Luger the bee Eugene drowner and honey
or something
how is he controlling
Eugene controls the bees he's a wicker
man
[Music]
Candyman
Eugene's a candy man it's a species here
that's what you get for messing with
Nevermore
[ __ ] Hummers stick together yeah all of
them and what irony the plant lady gets
taken down by bees yeah yeah
ain't it
feels like an old school movie her mom
is going to be like you're such a
disappointment you couldn't even defeat
the hide yes you're not wolf enough
where's Wednesday
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you too yeah bruh
lurch
is she still going home it's a fake out
it's just for the winter break or
something school might be closed
[Music]
question mark yeah
oh man they really killed her off I'm
Legit sad about that it's so fun to
watch when I was in the show I said a
lot of things being your friend should
come with a warning label but I don't
know a lot of people who would take an
arrow for me so
welcome to the 21st century Adams
nice
buy her a phone
my number's in there already I hope
you're not expecting me to call you
no never
I'd settle for a text though
[Music]
I don't know what a text is right
I wonder what a Wednesday text reads
like
[Music]
oh golly
oh [ __ ]
oh no maybe this forced vacation will be
more interesting than I imagined
unlike my novel not every thread has
been tied up nor every question answered
secrets are still lurking in the dark
corners who's the stalker is there a
Tyler in there or Laurel Gates and Tyler
just pawned in a bigger game
well today's stalker become tomorrow's
nemesis
[Music]
what the hell guys I know the suspense
is killing you
it is
give me more
I am
it's good
I mean there was something after the
credits I don't think Netflix would be
recommending Glass Onion that's true
and immediately skipping us ahead to the
idea that season two is coming yeah but
I mean we can uh wait I want a solid ass
season finale yeah man that was a really
solid season finale yeah it wrapped up
everything very satisfying very
cathartic very fun all right
let's go over everything we got right
yes
Tyler or Tyler that's about it Tyler and
I said oh wait no in in in in episode
three I said
that
uh oh my God forget his name right now
crack stone wood would come back
and
um
we didn't really commit to Christina
Ritchie no no
after Ricky Lynn at home that's the fun
thing about this we can we can't Pat
ourselves on the back for that I was
like oh okay we can only Pat ourselves
on the back for the idea that I think we
suspected something's up with her but
throughout we kept picking up on the
idea that that there's something not
being said about her and she is too they
both go out of their way to tell you
tell us that she's ignore me and she's
just too like good she's just like the
one character who's always good and not
like too gray and so yeah I said the
episode with her parents Enid that she a
wolf out on episode eight you did or was
it was it her parents it was some
episode something about that about not
being able to Wolfhound I was like wait
till episode eight I know I work on all
these edits so I know yeah
um
yeah
but
um okay yeah that's about it but we
don't we can't give ourselves Christina
Ritchie see that's the fun thing is
there had multiple she wasn't bad uh
Gwendolyn Christie wasn't bad I thought
I thought some there's gonna be some
other uh we couldn't we couldn't
pinpoint it
we couldn't nail down whether or not she
was bad yeah up until the very it wasn't
until she revealed herself like she's
undercover I was like oh she's good yeah
she is good what do you know no I
thought they did really well they did
really well with especially that mislead
and the mislead of of uh Dr kenbot like
yes I think they did nicely to tear out
Mysteries and I almost wonder if the
Tyler twist is sort of intentionally the
one you can most easily guess uh because
yeah you have that which is the Bell
we've been rigging this whole time uh
but then they have yeah these these
other mysteries on top as well as good
red herrings and I love that you get a
dramatic punch out of the idea that yeah
Weems is willing to bend the rules and
do some deceptive things for the greater
good of the school but as it turns out
it really is it's for the greater good
of the school you know yeah yeah I mean
there's a lot there there's a couple
things that I craved a tad bit more out
of
I feel like they keep giving the sheriff
the sled head when it comes to these
emotional beats because I wanted a
better scene with him in Gomez
sure him and then him and Tyler don't
get that scene come on give us
something about him being like my son
but you know I should have been more
involved emotionally with you after we
did talk about your mom I should have
learned my lesson yeah we should have
had we should have had because there was
no payoff to that after after everything
would you talk about ma
um or wanted that I did want that yeah
and
um I think the handle I really loved a
lot of the spookiness and it was just a
boisterous episode it was exciting it
felt like very Hollywood you know and I
really I love that touch I love that I
love that Flair it's like a it's not a
Halloween episode but it it sings of the
Halloween spirit sure you know like what
with the seances and the resurrection
and these Frankenstein nods and sure the
makeup of them and then the werewolfing
out and the fight like I was so it was
fun and exciting and it was great it was
a great pulse about it throughout the
whole episode episode and Eugene having
some ability to control the Beast okay
okay he's a Candyman or a wicker man or
some kind of zero is there a term for
that I don't I don't no no we're looking
it up because yeah do they explicitly
say what his uh what his ability or what
his you know category of uh otherness is
ability to control that's right he is at
Nevermore yeah yeah that's right for
sure yeah we thought he was just some
guy at the at the B place because I feel
like they they go out of their way to be
like vampires werewolves Sirens you know
and then we got hides I guess uh and the
manipulation is the ability
well
as I recall it anyway that's kind of all
they give you is sort of like that's
where they meet and that's most of where
you see him and they're doing B stuff
and and they don't really get too
personal about like why are you at
Nevermore what what kind of outcast are
you Eugene why don't you do an info dump
on you yeah like we learned more about
who Eugene is as a person in other ways
but yeah it is kind of funny to be like
oh yeah what is the what is the actual
extent of your power because of course
you must have some kind of power yeah or
just disposite I guess Wednesday is
special
she's got the Visions but even before
realizing that I guess she is there's
got to be a special auxiliary category
for people who are just a bit off and
strange and and outside of the you know
accepted normal the I like a lot of the
emotional payoffs like I really like the
way the hug was done with Enid and
Wednesday
yeah
said she would hug first episode said
she would hug Pugsley
nah she did hugging
you know Pugsley it's a mystery episode
of guessing you know come on you like to
figure out what you can get right yeah
yeah it's the whole fun of a show like
this across the board but uh you hugged
you know but the way that hug it was
just perfectly acted too yes like the
way I love the way they edited that with
the slow motion and then her pushing her
away like you don't realize until it
goes behind yeah he did it she's pushing
her away it's so funny they've played
the fury yeah but the hug was like such
a tight one like the closed Fist and
everything it wasn't just some you know
typical embrace it was like a
she closes her eyes there at the end
like this hug will kind of continue like
yeah it's a really lovely moment the
growth of having friendships I think
that was really strong yeah I did really
love the scene when Tyler Reveals His
True Colors I thought that was
excellently done where you're like oh
holy [ __ ] he's just an [ __ ] oh my God
he's been pretending this time he's
aware of it all oh my God
well that's a that's a good I think
another great little it's like yeah it's
it's a sub mystery but it's like okay so
Tyler must be the monster but you almost
assume that he must just not know and
then having that layer is like oh no
like it still manages to have a reveal
on top of the reveal you were expecting
which I think helps and is nice is good
however proceeding with Tyler in the
episode he did just become kind of one
now he just because yeah he just becomes
muscle Hench yeah yeah I know what and
he became a lot less interested and I
was like well as much as I love that
scene and the way that was done he is
just relegated backwards a little bit
and he has one note so he's nowhere near
as interesting to watch where I'm like
but if they did the choice where he he
was like a real Jekyll and Hyde
situation I thought they were setting
that up I don't know that was the
mislead was that they were setting up
that he is like a Jekyll and Hyde
and that's why the there's a turn at the
at the at the police station where he's
like how does it feel to lose like it's
a great line reveal yeah but
if they committed to the Jekyll and Hyde
thing he might have remained a little
bit more interesting that's what I'm
saying is it because they'd bother to
show that bit where you're seeing some
flashback of or he's listening to the
tapes the dad's listening to the tapes
of kinbot's sessions and her being like
whenever I bring up his mom he changes
and gets really cold and and it's not
like he's hulking out but it seems like
oh yeah there's a different personality
in there maybe he was at first and then
Christina Ricci uh maybe that's it yeah
it's like maybe when it's latent it just
is your demeanor but when it's really
unlocked it's the full spectrum or
something yeah and I I thought that was
a really well done
um I I think Christina Ritchie had a ton
of fun I think it was smart
it that is good casting because even the
moments early on like when it came to
her first learning about the secret
society it was very obvious the way
Christina was she played it like
oh no I don't
I don't know she obviously knew about
the Nightshade Society uh the way how
she would sometimes play off like she
doesn't know something but you're like
she clearly knows yeah um
however but casting her works on a great
audience level because you're like it's
Wednesday I trust that's trust that's
great meta casting so you're not really
going to you know fully expect it yeah
it said throws you off till close to the
end which I thought was really well done
like I fully believed it was the
therapist when they said it yeah
um yeah totally it wasn't until they got
rid of her was like oh my because it has
to be Christina Ritchie now yeah yeah
yeah so uh that the way that's that
reveals done and she does become you
know the thing is so much of it is saved
by it's it's it it the way it Embraces
its camp and the way it Embraces its
heightened spirit and like yeah does she
become just I'm evil villain now like
yeah she does this correct Stone just
become
monster back from the dead
I don't care about anything yeah yeah
yeah like does it become that sure but
it's it has such a great fun tone and
the production with it to support that
tone so that's why I'm like sure could
you do a little bit more I absolutely
you could and and I'm not just giving it
a pass because of that it I feel like
it's they did what I get the impression
they did what they wanted to do you know
and I like I really liked it a lot what
they decided to do and it did feel
ultimately fulfilling by the end well
yeah because it's not the most important
thing to do it's like you could have had
crack Stones return be
you could have had that span over you
know in a differently structured season
maybe it would have uh hit on episode
seven and then concluded in episode 8 so
you could really see what the full
extent of his being back means but yeah
he's he's just a big bad that we need to
Vanquish and I think they yeah it's like
it could have been expanded but I think
they chose to focus on the most
important things to give you know
resonance to and to pay off and then I
don't think they rushed anything with
him it's like you know you know what his
deal is going to be he's gonna come back
he's gonna be an initially grateful to
Thornhill for raising him up and then
he's gonna go off to his own ass thing
and we've got to put a stop to that so
like yeah as much as it would be like
neat to flesh him out and make him feel
like some kind of compelling interesting
villain there's they've done so much
work on so many other things and I think
that again is a nice thing looking back
because they do give you a lot to focus
on and a lot lot of nice red herrings
and a lot of things that you know amount
to Something in the greater tapestry but
also you know were fun additions to this
you know propulsive mystery
she get I guess the geoc I didn't watch
that dance episode it's like sprinting
what is the geography of the yeah yeah
sprinting into the woods and I gotta
make sure I go around so far away yeah
yeah uh I mean she's gotta know the
woods better than she's been there for
so long she knows the place but yeah it
is a little bit like what are you doing
off screen and I wonder if the stalker
if you can go back and watch the episode
this season if you could figure if you
could possibly figure out who the
stalker is I would be fascinated to know
yeah somebody because yeah you can
triangulate at least what scenes to look
for them in based on those pictures
so you could maybe I don't know look at
some of those reverse shots in the
Weather Vein or whatever in the cafe I
have no idea who will be
it's Eugene
It's gotta be Eugene bastard or it's uh
the sheriff the dead Sheriff's not
Sheriff the mayor's son damn Lucas or
whatever his name is
I miss you Gwendolyn Christy I thought
you were great I know I'm sad and now I
feel bad and retrospect I'm like I'm
sorry I doubted you I wish I appreciated
you when you were alive I kind of did uh
Jenna Ortega is just uh killed this
entire performance it's not a single
week moment yeah she completely sells
and embodies the character and I I and
goodie too like I I really I really love
what she's done here because it's like
impressive but it also feels so natural
it's it's it feels
you know I mean Christina Ritchie's
Wednesday Adams is pretty definitive and
this feels absolutely definitive so like
you know props like well done
yeah and I think it was cool to make her
the villain because it completely washes
away I feel like it's completely
recontextualizes like on a repeat watch
yeah like I was watching it as a
revealing it kind of getting annoyed at
myself
of like
yeah yeah which is I think a good a good
Twist Again a good twist reveal when
you're like man
should have committed him hitting this
on her yeah because yeah there's a there
was a decent amount and even 10 gentle
things like you think about one of the
details we used and Wednesday uses to be
like oh kinbot it's you as those flowers
and you're like well who else is
involved with flowers though you know
like you could even extrapolate things
like that exactly yeah yeah
exactly [ __ ] like this is one of those
shows that I'm now excited to go back
and rewatch yeah that is a great clue
bastards bastards man but yeah I I I
think the the growth and journey of
Wednesday I feel like they really do a
nice job to keep her authentic and to
never betray The Roots but to really
show what growth looks like and what
vulnerability and what friendship looks
like to a character like this
and I don't know I've seen a lot of
people's just responses out in the world
being very grateful for that because
it's kind of shedding light on an
experience that isn't as mainstream in
culture anyway for certain people who do
you know experience life in a more
wednesday-esque fashion I don't know
yeah
it's like so well lived in So Perfect
they're annoying those people are idiots
all right people comic strip character
it's complete fiction we're talking
about a fictional character not real
life yeah you guys need to get your [ __ ]
together Harry Potter's not really it's
just a society be normal yeah being the
message of the show is to be normal and
keep your head down
don't step out of line or call too much
attention to yourself
you'll get ripped apart by monsters yeah
I mean overall I thought this was a
really fun episode a fun season I
thought this was really really fun and I
see what the excitement's all about
because from beginning to end it's
it uh it was a progressive blast and you
know they flesh out all these friends
but they don't flesh out everyone by the
end
the other characters I'm like I don't
really know this person I'm like I can't
name who that guy you don't know Yoko by
now I know Yoko because I was like Yoko
the Asians Yoko oh no the name Yoko Ono
yeah of course
um so I have like subconscious reasons
of applying your name
um but yeah you have this whole cast of
Friends who stand by her in the end but
you know it's really because of
Bianca and The Nightshade society and
whatever uh and and who plays Enid
oh goodness it's everyone's names and
you look up everyone's names now I know
I I almost committed it to memory during
the opening credits that we commented on
but now I can't remember but she's great
something Sinclair
yes I want to say
none of us can Google it comment it
below guarantee you we haven't looked it
up we will haven't looked it up by the
time this has done being edited and
uploaded we have now looked it up yeah
no she's she's terrific too and I was
and I loved uh I loved I mean obviously
you know you know she's gonna she's got
a wolf out at some point I liked that
yeah she gets to throw down and to
really like you know break in the wolf
skin but also I really like the way they
played the end of that and I loved that
shot where she and Ajax it's that wide
profile shot of them where he kind they
stop and then he rushes to her because
she's feeling so kind of vulnerable in
that moment and so shaken by the
experience and the way they like it's a
classic kind of a shot where it's like
you're going through the crowd and the
crowd is like oh [ __ ] I felt like a old
school Hollywood set too when when he
does go up to her it felt like out of a
black and white like uh horror film yeah
yeah and I like to horror films so many
great little flourishes like that yeah
totally totally and yeah and even if you
don't necessarily get to know every one
of the other kids it's like they
included them enough that it felt like a
real population of students and a real
sort of like oh yeah I kind of know that
guy I kind of know that guy you know
this is like just enough I mean it's a
full series so you know if this was the
end I would go oh I don't want to say
this I want to see that oh I wish you
had seen this because they introduced so
many different types of beings that you
don't get to explore really but they
keep it focused on the mystery at hand
and that's what's important that you got
to deal with uh you know you gotta see
some of the siren abilities a little bit
you know but they at the beginning of
the first episode they're like
werewolves vampires Sirens you know
they're they're listing them off you
don't really get to see too much of that
well that's the thing is this leaves you
with a nice amount of anticipation
because I sit here and I go well I'm
excited to come back to school anyway
like you know a season two will have
some school stuff and I'm excited for
that because I enjoyed that here I'm
excited to potentially see more of this
world's take on different creatures I'm
excited for the idea that each season
would probably have a different murder
mystery or mystery of some kind at hand
and two watching this sounds like they
have a very specific mystery set up yes
well yeah the stalker she's probably
gonna have to do like a Clarice
startling thing and visit
Tyler Tyler that's right yeah because he
sees everything being the Barista in
town someone's following me that's right
you must know who it is and then I'm I'm
sitting here going
thinking maybe specifically towards
Buffy I'm like as much as I'm sad
principal Williams is gone I bet that
they could just have a new principle
every season and then kill them and get
a new principle every season I don't
know there's just like so much fun
potential and then also as much as I
feel like like for me it's not a big
deal like I'm I've been so thrilled with
what we've been you know enjoying here
but you know there's more you can do
with the various members of The Addams
Family too which is just a nice
potential to have on the horizon I want
a Fester episode every season I think
they should do some type of Netflix
special like an hour and a half Adams
Family episode that would be so cool I
think that would be a great like
something in between school do a holiday
special yeah I think that would be a
really cool thing to do before season
two comes out yeah or or The Addams
family visits San Francisco
Uncle Fester in there
there's so much you could do yeah yeah I
think that would be a nice little
Netflix gets an original movie out of it
yeah and we got and we got Justice for
Xavier we gotta we gotta mention him and
he's I guess gonna pay because his dad's
Rich they're just gonna pay for
Wednesday's phone plan
it's like give her a phone with like a
that works that works right and someone
got the number yeah already
but I'm not buying that again all right
I'm not buying the Xavier is in any way
involved with that
are you stalking yeah I'm like unknown
number of luggages Xavier's number
Xavier it's cooler when you say Xavier
because of X-Men
who would it be
um who's that girl who's not Yoko but
who's always around it's her no idea
that girl with the slick hair who who's
something or other maybe it's uh
dude maybe it's that kid with one
testicle from the very first episode
with the piranhas and now he's a freak
because he only has one testicle so he
has to go to Nevermore
and he's the stalker
well dang all right guys
um this was a fun fun show
um sad it's over apparently's been a
really really fun Journey
uh but I'm excited for season two uh
which has already been announced wasn't
she nominated she got a Golden Globe
nomination is she Jenna Ortega yeah did
she I think she did I hope so I mean
it's a it is a definitive performance
and it's got
she's a superstar right now yeah yeah
and yeah no she is and I mean she's
already been making a name she's already
been standing out in so many things and
now it was I feel like it was only a
matter of time before she got something
like this but this is like the the best
possible scenario yeah before I even
knew who she was I remember watching
scream and yeah I think in our review I
was like she's whoever this actually she
should be this she's the best one in the
whole movie yeah totally no I love
watching her like I I love it's it's
funny there's a lot about the character
that's easy to appeal to me anyway but
like I love watching all the life going
on under that deadpan surface because
there is so much and she does so much
with a very restricted emotional
performance which I think is great it
never feels restricted even though she
is you know so uh you know laconic and
uh and yeah you know stone-faced much of
the time yeah she's my hair yeah man
she's great
all righty well
thank you guys for being here
be sure to uh subscribe leave a like
what are you hoping for in Wednesday
season two what was your favorite moment
pinpoint it your favorite moment out of
all of Wednesday how many Mysteries did
you call leave it all down below yeah be
sure to subscribe and hey let's see who
the lucky Patron
flev Doran you would drive in Wednesday
Adam's crazy man you would annoy the
[ __ ] out of her because you are so
colorful and cheerful you would be like
like a like a Romanian Enid is what you
would be and I think that's what the
show needs next season is a guy like you
in the mix you know bringing your your
optimism and your enthusiasm and you
know seeing how that plays off the goth
Macabre Vibes emitted by so many
different characters on this show but uh
you know what no matter how much light
and color might encroach upon the dark
we try to give off you can't help but be
susceptible to it flavior
you've got an infectious energy and no
matter where you show up with it I'm
always like I'm happy to hear from flev
so uh hey bud I hope you watched this
and I hope you liked it and I hope you
like yourself and I hope you like living
in 2023 because we're glad you're still
here with us never on pledge
or we will uh we'll we'll hide out we'll
turn into hides and we'll come get you
love you buddy
stay oh
you just don't stop talking enough for
me to get that into silence
wait what
[Music]